Take a closer look
now with
CNN military analyst
and retired Air Force
Colonel Cedric Leighton.
Good to have you on, sir.
So let's take a look at this mess.
It looks very close
to the Ukrainian border.
But to be frank,
this is 25 miles inside
Russian territory.
And as you know,
a lot of this territory here
is actually controlled
by Russian forces as well.
So how surprising is a miss?
I imagine there was intended for a target
somewhere over here.
It's quite surprising, Jim.
And the reason it's so surprising
is that these aircraft,
the SU 30,
34, is designed to go ahead and
and actually use a
be used as a stand off weapon.
So as a standoff weapon,
it can use these missiles
to go attack targets very far away.
When this weapon when this bomb came off,
it was probably a weapon
that was designed
in the old Soviet
era and had been modified
with GPS and wings.
And as a result of that, those wings
probably failed to deploy.
And instead of going straight forward
it went down and hit an intersection
right in the middle of Belgorod.
The US has these help as well.
They're called JDAMs.
You basically put some,
you know, wings on there
that you can control.
So what you're saying, in effect,
it was meant to fire somewhere over here,
stand off
or over the horizon
and instead
dropped on on Russian territory?
That's one possible scenario.
The other scenario is that
it was a deliberate act
because it hit
right in the intersection
of a major street.
And that is also kind of unusual,
to say the least.
And of course, that's a civilian target.
And that's something that, you know,
should not have happened at all.
Here's the other issue here,
and this is a bigger picture problem
for Russian aircraft,
and that is that Ukrainian air defenses,
they're not perfect.
We see bombs and missiles
dropping all the time,
but they have effectively made
Ukrainian territory
a no fly zone for Russian aircraft
because the air defenses are significant
enough to
to put those pilots,
those Russian pilots in danger.
Is that a disadvantage
to Russian forces that they have to fire
from this side of the border in effect?
It is absolutely.
Because if they were able
to have air supremacy over Ukraine,
they could fly anywhere
throughout the entire country
because they can't do that
because the systems are good enough
to prevent a lot of that flying.
They did not achieve
air supremacy
or air superiority
throughout the entire airspace
of Ukraine.
That means that this particular situation
could happen much more frequently.
And it also means that the Russians
are at a considerable disadvantage
in targeting.
They can target as accurately as they
otherwise would be able to listen.
And as we said, it was a significant miss
that's the size of the crater there.
But it's notable.
Remember, early
on, the assessments were that
Russia would have to
establish superiority
or supremacy in the air
in the early stages of the war,
where more than a year later
and they haven't been able to do it.
CNN's Nick Paton Walsh is live for us
in eastern Ukraine.
Nick, what is the Kremlin saying about
what happened
Yeah, very little.
And frankly,
apart from that,
this was essentially an accident
that is under investigation,
according to Russian state media.
Obviously, deeply embarrassing
but perhaps
less embarrassing
than admitting
that this sort of explosion
may have been caused
by Ukrainian armed forces.
This is an issue.
34 strikes jets
its entirely unclear
whether the munition
simply fell off the aircraft
as it was flying over Belgorod
City to the northeast of Ukraine,
not far from its border,
or if there was some other mistaken
targeting or firing incident here.
As you say,
it caused a significant crater
that a lot of damage
to the site of an apartment block,
leaving one woman with brain
trauma head injuries
and another woman with lacerations
that were treated on the scene.
Remarkable, frankly,
that it didn't kill
more Russian civilians.
But also for those in Ukraine, often
the target of indiscriminate, inaccurate,
appallingly judged indiscriminate
bombing against civilians.
Little comfort to see it happen
to Russian citizens, too.
But we are with some women
who've been sheltering
in a basement of an apartment
block for months
when they heard the news over the radio.
And to them,
they said it was the best thing
we had heard of in a while.
But still an appalling sign of Russia's
military effectiveness.
And Nick, the NATO's
secretary general is in Germany right now
meeting with Ukrainian officials.
Jens Stoltenberg saying
that Ukraine's future is in NATO's.
But he didn't give a
timeline for that, correct?
Yeah, absolutely.
And of
course, bear in mind
that Ukraine were to join NATO
while it's at war with Russia
would automatically
assume be trigger
Article five
and then NATO's would be part
of that war as well.
And so a lengthy timeline
like clear heads
Ukraine's military
are rapidly equipped with NATO's
equipment is still far behind
the standards required to join NATO.
But here is the sentiments
echoed by the NATO's chief
all needs
allies have agreed that Ukraine
will become a NATO member,
but the main focus now is, of course,
on the on how to ensure that Ukraine
prevails.
Now, it's a very complex task.
It requires unanimity across
all of NATO's members.
It's even difficult to get Turkey
and Hungary
to fully sign on to Sweden
and Finland
too, aren't at war with Russia right now
to become part of NATO's.
But the key point
there is not to be distracted
from the key task at hand,
and that is getting all the munitions
that Ukraine needs now, tanks,
anti-aircraft, to assist
with the forthcoming
Ukrainian counteroffensive
that many think maybe hours or days away.
Back to you.
Jan, Stoltenberg
also saying
he wants Ukraine's
military to be up to NATO's
grade of weapons and munitions, etc..
Nick Paton Walsh from Ukraine,
thank you so much for that report.